[Musique]
un
joueur du grenier merci d'être venus oui
vous m'avez téléporter oui eh bien on
met bas porte un bonnet sur la planète
général a pas été détruites
effectivement mais cet épisode d paca
dont hockey et c'est pour ça que j'avais
changé de costume non ça c'est parce que
c'est chiant d'être le fondeur nous
étions en train de faire de notre grande
fête annuelle et une période de paix
d'amour et de traditions
[Musique]
libérez moi je n'ai que c'est tentant
despatie peu extrêmes comme tradition du
tout on s'offre des canaux aussi tenez
voilà un casque de réalité virtuelle et
signe le no merci c'est sympa mais
changez pas de sujet put on est en train
de parler de l'effet pour la cl et bio
fermez la et mettez ça
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut à tous et le mois de noël et qui
dit mois de noël dit
noël les spéciales noël c'est quand même
quelque chose de très américain on
trouve parfois des épisodes de noël dans
les animés japonais ou les trucs
européen mais il n'y a pas ce côté un
peu naïf tenant ou par là même parce que
c'est la période de l'année où tout le
monde doit s'aimer donc il est normal
que presque tous les spéciales noël soit
des trucs américain alors parfois c'est
un peu bizarre comme le spécial noël de
la série house qui est trop long pour
expliquer mais qui se termine par la
mort d'une petite fille qui n'a plus
d'amis et qui est en phase finale d'une
maladie dans mon dos je vais être obligé
d'y vivre maintenant tête que noël dure
pendant toute l'année tu pourrais rester
avec moi jusqu'à ce que je me suis
endormi
vous
[Rires]
en
bas se consoler en se disant que c'était
juste une histoire
[Musique]
en tulle alors évidemment il y en a
beaucoup trop pour tous les bras c'est
un les chipmunks pacman peter pan du
coup on va juste se contenter des deux
premiers de la liste et on va commencer
par musclor
iman de musclor de sombrer titre les
maîtres de l'univers en français alors
je regardais pas spécialement cette
série est un peu vieux pour moi elle a
été produite en 1982 l'année où je suis
né hors mes premiers souvenirs de
dessins animés au monde plutôt à la fin
des années 80 et à ce moment là on avait
déjà des dessins animés japonais
vachement mieux animé par ce qu on va
pas se mentir un musclor ou chira ça
ressemblait à ça je ne peux pas trop
bouger mon corps donc on va se contenter
de nîmes et mes lèvres attendait
maintenant je dois courir
alors pour les jeunes qui regarde cette
vidéo le principe des maîtres de
l'univers c'était simple la mère de
musclor était à la base une astronaute
terrienne qui après une mission qui
tourne mal a dû se poser en catastrophe
sur la planète eternia alors je vais
croiser les doigts et essayer de me
poser centre 15
[Musique]
millions qu'elle était coincée sur la
planète et décida de se taper le roi
pour donner naissance à adam prince
dernière qui peut se métamorphoser en
musclor grâce au pouvoir du crâne
ancestral et bizarrement quand il fait
ça plus personne ne le reconnaît
attendez son identité secrète c'est se
[ __ ] à poil la série les maîtres de
l'univers était d'ailleurs relativement
connue pour le côté homo érotique qui
s'en dégage et de manière plus ou moins
volontaire parce qu'on parle d'une série
où tout le monde et [ __ ] de bars à
quai et en slip et affrontent des
ennemis [ __ ] de bars à quai et en slip
je veux dire où est la logique là tu as
une armure en eau et un slip d'ours en
bas et site ajoute à ça que musclor il a
l'air de feu jouir dessus chaque fois
qu'il fait le moindre effort ou de
certains épisodes comme celui là où il
affronte le mec qui s'appelle fisto
fisto et son pote à piste aucune
araignée qui tire
bref voilà ya eu aussi au passage
vaguement une tentative de faire la
version pour filles avec chirac est un
miroir de la série mais en version
féminine pourquoi il doit appeler chira
et chimanes d'ailleurs ou shimell et
comme c'est un jean pour filles a
évidemment il ya des licornes des
sirènes des petits lutins et les os son
homologie rien dit il et plutôt badass
en fait on dirait un peu aragorn sous sa
capuche je l'aï les verts de cet homme
un esclave
je sais déjà
bref voilà donc pour résumer c'est
beaucoup plus coloré évidemment comme
toutes les séries américaines elle a eu
droit à son spécial noël retrouve donc
le palais d'été revient en pleine
préparation pour
[Musique]
gay pride bref tout le monde prépare
l'anniversaire des jumeaux et pour le
coup même chira et ses amis sont venus
depuis leur planète regardez même le
prince de lu est venu superviser tout ça
j'irai au bout de mon château les
[ __ ] et pendant ce temps-là musclor
et le maître d'armes sont en train de
tester une fusée pour surveiller ce que
les torts mais évidemment orco 1 le
petit personnage secondaire locaux tout
le monde déteste arracher le morceau de
métal et démarre la fusée skeletor
essais d'intercepter la fusée mais
musclor fonce à la rescousse pour aider
orco
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
malheureusement orco s'échapper par en
vitesse lumière pour arriver sur terre
je crois bien que tu peux dire adieu à
ta fusée heureusement il n'y avait
personne à bah ouais attendez vous
n'êtes pas dans l'espace léo fait ah oui
merde
arrivé sur terre au recours rencontrer
sauf deux petits enfants qui étaient
partis pour chercher un sapin dans la
montagne je cherchais un arbre de noël
et puis voilà on s'est perdus ouais
normal
attendait non les arts de noël ça
s'achète à auchan c'est qu'ils leur part
en bon à prendre j'ai coupé sa pub en
fait attention aux bourses bref orco
invite les enfants à les suivre dans son
vaisseau spatial chose qu'ils acceptent
sans se poser la moindre question pour
bestiaux s'est écrasé au pied des 7
collines à l'étuvée mois et pourquoi mon
camp je fais ça en vrai ça marche jamais
les flots petit enfant a laissé moi dans
mon vaisseau fabienne regarde bien
bref pendant que les enfants raconte
l'histoire de noël à orco après il
entend curé et puis ils ont dit sur une
croix avant de lui bien d une lance dans
le ventre et de le laisser mourir de
faim et depuis on fête la naissance
voilà jeté raconté le passage aussi où
ils ont fait assassiner tous les bébés
du royaume les secours s'organisent et
chira pas rechercher un cristal sur la
planète polly pocket avec l'aide de mme
amistat une sirène mais sur le chemin
chira se fait attaquer par des robots
qui l'enferment dans une bulle hercules
et robots tout ce qu'on avait fait
finalement c'était juste de s'introduire
dans votre ville pour voler votre
cristal
section monstre horrible nous devons
rejoindre notre nom trop grâce aux
pluies pour nous préparer au combat je
comprends la manse route non ils ont
installé un monstre au radar mais malgré
la situation désespérée chirac on compte
comme plan génial pour s'échapper des
abandons ce qui est important bref le
cristal de chira permet de ramener orco
sur sa planète mais bordel mais là ces
gamins ici et vous pourquoi est-ce que
vous acceptez de le suivre quand est ce
qu'on aura des gamins qui réagiront
normalement pour une fois dans un dessin
animé tu ne nous présente pas tes amis
pardon voici et richard enegel ce sens
de nouveaux sacrifices pour satan
bref voyant les enfants arrivés sur
eternia pour raconter l'origine de noël
le chef des méchants qui s'appelle le
maître de la horde décide donc de
concentrer ses efforts sur l'esprit de
noël ouais en musclor scheer à la
conquête du monde on s'en branle arrêté
tour gère les enfants d'abord parce que
le temps il a l'air de trouver le plan
complètement con tu peux parler dès que
tu vois musclor arrive et et joe se
change en gelée tu crois ça si tu vu moi
je t'ai fait goûter mais en
attendant il vient pas de lui proposer
de le sucer là bref nous revoilà donc
sur la planète eternia où les enfants
décident d'expliquer à tout le monde de
l'esprit de noël et c'est le décor de
rêve pour interpréter ma nouvelle
chanson on ne repart pas une chanson non
pas une chanson s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
et je pensais pas dire ça un jour mais
dieu merci une énorme beat arrive dans
le ciel pour interrompre la chanson
chirac comment la beauce et lui l'allié
de chira essaye de les intercepter mais
les méchants arrivent donc avec les
enfants sur leurs bases a été rien quand
soudain
plus si vous faites exprès un bon bref
alors les monstres aux ide capture les
enfants mais ceux ci sont libérés par
musclor et des rebuts de il était une
fois la vie avant d'être recapturer pour
la troisième fois aujourd'hui parce que
les torts mais ça fait beaucoup pour une
seule journée et bref la fin c'est
l'autoroute 1 skeletor de bien gentil
grâce à l'esprit de noël et à la barbe
du chien qui le laisse pendant quatre
minutes environ ce devient super gênant
au bout d'un moment et ils les aident à
s'échapper baston bassan parce que c'est
ça l'esprit de noël et à la fin musclor
offre une ceinture volante aux enfants
[Musique]
c'est pas du tout ce que j'espérais et
en même temps je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
continué à regarder ça jusqu'au bout
c'est dommage vous avez raté le
sacrifice des déserts
[Musique]
délicieux c'est quoi un sens de la
victime évidemment
c'est très bon
j'ai pas fin aux messieurs le vice-roi
frangipane us il tonnerre ou souhaiter
de bonnes fêtes de fin d'année bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année ouais c'est vrai
que j'avais ça aussi vous savez quoi je
vais réessayer mon cadeau star wars le
hasard du calendrier fait que le
huitième épisode de la saga sort à peu
près au moment où cette vidéo doit
sortir alors si on met de côté le 8e si
vous êtes un vieux de la vieille vous
avez vu le cas de 5,6 si vous êtes un
passionné vous avez vu le 1 2 3 4 5 6 si
vous êtes un acharné vous avez vu les
huit films en comptant revoit hne et le
numéro 7 et si vous êtes un gros con
vous avez vu les neuf star wars
christmas pétioles un film de 1h30 créée
en 1978 un an après la sortie du premier
film star wars est traduit en français
en 1979 cet épisode a été si mauvais que
george lucas ça complètement désavoué le
film est à rechercher des copies à
travers le monde pour les faire
disparaître le film commence donc par du
stock footage du premier film avec en
solo et chewbacca qui essayent de fuir
une patrouille de leurs pires afin
d'assister à son anniversaire ne
t'inquiète pas on pourra célébrer
l'anniversaire et pascal r ouais alors
déjà rien que par la trop en 100 kg a
pas de moyens allez mon petit chou et
prépare toi on va passer en vitesse
linéaire
ah oui au passage la vf sont torcher le
cul puisque son père en vo devient son
frère enfanté centenaire ritchie le
titre passe de star wars holiday special
as autant de la guerre des étoiles et en
solo et chewbacca qui était censé se
rendre une célébration intitulé le jour
de la vie en vo maintenant se rendent à
on pourra célébrer l'anniversaire épais
ce cas là c'est devenu l'anniversaire de
chewbacca s'ensuit une présentation des
différents acteurs avec une carrie
fisher qui est la tête de quelques
complètement défoncé en soit réactivée
en compte une blague
et à et on me dit dans l'oreillette au
passage qu'elle était réellement défoncé
puisque c'est à cette époque là
précisément qu'elle a commencé à prendre
de la drogue
c'était noël qui s'annonce bien alors
surtout si vous prenez actuellement des
médicaments je vous déconseille de
regarder cette vidéo puisque la pression
sanguine qui va en résulter peut
provoquer vomissements diarrhées et
risque d'avc je vais donc posé cette
boîte ici et de pluie retouché jusqu'à
la fin de ce film la première scène donc
se passe à la maison de chewbacca alors
que toute la famille attend le retour de
chewie
[Musique]
alors là pour les besoins de la vidéo je
voulais couper mais en vrai je vous jure
que ça dure une éternité
c'est pire que de regarder quelqu'un
manger son cacao aura un 10 minutes
10 minutes dit [ __ ] de minutes de
bruit de trompettes qui sent qu lavande
en fait entendre quelqu'un prononcer un
mot et l'absence de sous titres n'est
pas un oubli de la vf c'est vraiment dix
minutes ils n'attendront plus de salles
[Musique]
je vais me permettre pour vous d'ajouter
des sous titres histoire d'améliorer la
compréhension de la scène
[Musique]
je
désolé je me suis laissé emporter c'est
ce que je ressentais au moment où j'ai
écrit les sous titres bref donc après
cinq heures environ de hurlements de
loups qui le grand-père foulquier ou qui
devant la télé et on a droit à un
spectacle façon cirque du soleil et
c'est moi vous ce petit ou killer en
plus d'être moche comme une merde
fraîchement sorti de qu il a une tête
absolument terrifiante je suis
mais voyant que chewbacca et en solo
n'arrive pas à la femme de chewbacca
décide donc de contacter luc très occupé
à réparer
une machine à fumée visiblement et qui
est devenue une [ __ ] de statues de
cire sans aucune expression regarder ça
alors pour l'anecdote ainsi lucas une
tête de bougies qui fait le trottoir
c'est parce qu'ils l'ont sorti de
l'hôpital trois semaines à peine après
son grave accident de voiture juste pour
tourner ça alors heureux qu rajma là il
va bientôt arriver allez je te laisse je
vais affronter d'agréer monsieur mais on
retourne à l'hôpital bref c'est suivante
où la femme de chewbacca se dit tiens je
vais me brancher sur la caméra du
magasin de tapis à grosse intrigue et on
a donc droit à une scène surréaliste de
garde impériale qui fait ses courses
ce titre j'ai même qu'est ce qu'ils
regardent la ve sacs en plastique
j'ai beaucoup trop de temps libre
regardez c'est un minuscule aquarium et
ne nécessite que très peu d'eau je
déteste ces liquides
qualo donc la femme de chewbacca
commandes au tapis pour sa maison puis
on revient sur le vendeur qui explique
au garde impériale le mode d'emploi
d'une brosse une brosse c'est juste une
grosse une brosse évidemment on n'avait
pas lu le mode d'emploi qui figure sur
la garantie bien que cet appareil soit
qu'une brosse rasoir il enlève l'état
sur les vêtements les visages et tout le
reste ils lavent les dents permet de se
faire les ongles nettoient les yeux
personne les oreilles calcul les
modulations du système nerveux est en
mesure de citer le pod impérial bien qu
clairement que le prêtre l'avocat et en
moitié moins de temps que le vieux xp 21
ont un autre avantage de ces véritables
petites merveilles on peut le recharger
en le branchant cinq minutes sur une
petite piste laser ordinaire c'est trop
fort
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est
pourquoi il les vaisseaux nous avons
établi un barrage et nous avons ordonné
une course e enfin nous on l'a d'abord
star wars
identifie même s'il faut ou des chats
d'une des maisons qui concerne au
système
[Musique]
pourquoi vous faites ça qu'est ce que ça
va être maintenant une recette de
cuisine aujourd'hui nous allons préparer
une spécialité où heureusement
succulentes
tourner tourner côté ballet tournée
de drôle en plus c'est juste quatre
minutes de moore qui cuisine on a eu
droit à 15 secondes de dark vador et
maintenant ces cinq minutes entières de
ça
quelques voix la blague le temps est ce
que quelqu'un voit la [ __ ] de blague
et en plus dit vous qu'en filmant ils
ont dû refaire des prises est très
certainement comment ce tournage ne
s'est pas finie en fusillade ça me
dépasse
[Musique]
là on s'en fout la papc spatiaux on
mettait la [ __ ] qui cuisine bref
vous l'aurez compris cet épisode c'est
1h30 d'enchaînements de scène sans aucun
rapport avec star wars et sans aucun
lien entre elles et lui ont dû être
écrite je pense sincèrement par un
scénariste défonce à l'huile de vidange
est atteint d'une tumeur au cerveau dans
la scène suivante le vendeur de tapis
qu'on a aperçu un peu plus tôt arrive
dans la maison et installe papy devant
un casque virtuel
du coup
[Musique]
à un
bon dieu c'est du porno
[Musique]
je suis en train de regarder star wars
ou le père de chewbacca se branche dans
la cuisine sur un bordeaux interraciales
je pensais pas je regretterais charger
un jour et vous imaginez les menus de ce
dvd si ce truc était sorti la boutique
de brasse le tapis la recette de cuisine
passage vous l'avez vu à cette scène a
été censuré en france est donc quelque
part quelques s'est dit que montrer un
vieux ou qui se branlent à des enfants
s'étaient pas très noël bref après c'est
au tour de la scène de carrie fisher qui
est défoncée et qui visiblement obligé
d'être là par contre oui alors j'ai pris
1,80 secrétaire parce que ça paye patron
des princesses ont cependant puis
finalement enfin le vaisseau de han solo
et chewbacca arrive et voilà c'est fini
à les 16
[Musique]
mais non évidemment on n'a pas semblé
comme ça c'était pas le faucon
millénaire à 7 et des membres de l'
empire qui se mettent à contrôler la
maison à la recherche de chewbacca
on est d'accord que cet acteur niveau
rien du tout avec ce match alors je vais
passer sur cette scène et qui est
particulièrement inintéressante c'est
dire en gros c'est juste le vendeur de
tapis qui essaient de distraire les
soldats on les fout temps devant la télé
lehoux qui n'est pas là dedans mais je
vais encore continuer à regarder pendant
cinq ou six minutes le seul truc que je
retiens de tous deux films c'est
l'espèce de petits dessins animés à
mu d'ailleurs et pour l'anecdote ce truc
marque aussi la première apparition
officielle de boba fett bien avant son
apparition dans l'épisode 5 de star wars
bref dans pendant ce temps là les
méchants arrivent dans la chambre du
petit déchire les peluches et casse les
dictée magique parce qu'ils sont
méchants
nous avons fini bien vous tapez déchiré
tous les nounours et du coup le fils de
chewbacca curieux monde dans sa chambre
ils font quoi les gars de là ils ont
planté triste que les gardes et décapité
ses peluches il décide donc de faire
quelque chose d'utile au scénario
j'espère et donc brève ils
regardent une émission de télé achat et
nous sommes convaincus que lorsque vous
en disposez vous vous demanderez comment
vous avez pu vous en passer jusque là
ok ça lui quoi c'est bon je laisse
tomber
c'est fini je fais ce que tu veux je moi
je m'en fous ça me touche plus tout
d'abord je vous prenez le sachet en
plastique qui contient l'outillage
nécessaire au montage
il contient les autres
alors histoire de ne pas y passer des
heures je me suis permis de compiler
tous les moments destiné à normalement
vous faire rire
[Musique]
nos deux malaises qui cite le mal est
critique
mais
brave et petites routes la construction
de cet engin
sert à rien n'aurait pu et je sais pas
moi fabriquer un émetteur pour contacter
shoei pour lui dire papa au secours
l'empiré là les papilles se prend dans
la cuisine c'est le work life des
rêveurs mais non rosso ce fusil joue
sans fond du redois je sais pas quoi
dire sincèrement c'est 2-2 de la sodomie
cérébrale alors bon évidemment pour
finir sur mcafee enfin parvenir le
stoppe son corps d'un suicide et tout ce
petit monde par invoquer satan rend
visiblement dans une espèce de réunions
de mookie ultranationaliste à vous vous
rappelez du début ça vous dit un concert
de rookie
[Musique]
et au fini sur une petite chanson de
l'eia
[Musique]
m
deux ans
le monde
monde
oui
je
m
[Musique]
merci seigneur vador
ben c'était vraiment un jeune gars noël
de merde merci alpha 500 rien mais ce
c'est d'appeler cette veille de noël ça
s'appelle
[Musique]
allez je voyais fêtes de noël joyeux
noël motherfucker
[Musique]
m